[ ♫ Pamela Z’s Music ♫ ]
- When I first saw Pamela,
what I was really struck by was
this kind of holistic way in which
she approached technology, electronics.
And it was similar to the way
she approached her voice,
and in fact,
they bleed into each other
in really interesting ways,
and you can't have one without the other.
[Pamela Z demonstrates gesture controls]
- I teach a digital instrument design class
where we learn to create
digital musical instruments.
So basically we're working with sensors
and microcontrollers,
and Pamela
has been doing exactly that.
When she
came in and did her demonstration,
we talked about her sensors that she used,
we talked a lot about her
gestures, her approach to mapping.
- The instruments that I was using just now,
were that instrument,
which is my voice.
And then I was using several
different gesture control instruments
to manipulate the sounds,
sometimes just to play sampled sounds.
- Our students are very well educated
around the implications of systems
and how to implement things.
And to be able to get into a discussion
around the artistic
implications of those kinds
of decisions with an artist
who's living it all the time,
that's invaluable.
You can't get that kind of experience
really anywhere else.
- These instruments,
just like any other instruments,
have a gesture vocabulary that you learn,
and it comes from
playing the instrument
and how to get out of it
what you need.
When you're thinking
about instrument design,
does this instrument
give the user of the instrument
room to be expressive
with the instrument?
- We're involved in technology
here every day,
but really like, what is it for?
And when you're talking about something
like music or the arts,
I think it really is about helping people
express themselves
to make human experiences
that are interesting.
The focus always needs to be on,
how does this connect to people?
[ ♫ Pamela Z’s Music ♫ ]
- These tools,
machines, instruments,
whatever we're calling them,
I like to see those as something
that we express ourselves through them
rather than trying to train them
so that they
can take over the expression.
Here, I feel like this whole idea of art
and technology is much more integrated
and seen as a continuum
and not as these like separate things.
- I always feel like sometimes with like
electronic music that it can be so hard
to like, really feel like the audience
is always included in what's happening.
- Pamela and I share conceptual ideas
about having that
grounding in like our voices
being in the center of the material.
I think there's that connection
between how we feel about our voices,
how you feel about ourselves.
It is the only instrument
that really has that sort of embodied
nature living with inside us.
And I think technology for me
is kind of situated in like emphasizing
that sense of embodied control.
- I immediately started thinking,
what about larger?
And on a stand,
and so you're standing up
and now it's you're standing there,
you're with your audience,
and when you're manipulating it,
it's right in front of you.
And they see you,
you know, manipulating it as opposed
to it's a small thing on your table
and it's down and you're here
and you're at the computer.
And, you know, it's
almost like the difference
between gesturing at someone
or pointing at someone versus
putting your hand on their face
and stroking their cheek.
- The assignment that I gave to
Evan's class was that they all go out
and record a found sound.
[ ♫ Student Music ♫ ]
Sounds that were not necessarily intended
by the original maker
of that sound to be used in art.
And take that sound and make a very
short composition out of it.
- It really expanded
what my definition of music was.
Before I thought it was just
instruments and vocal parts
and things like that.
But now, like as I go about my daily life,
sometimes I'll hear a sound
and I'll just like, record it.
- Wow, there was this great moment
where the voices got really dense.
Suddenly we maybe were
let into some place or something.
It was a nice moment.
[ ♫ Pamela Z’s Music ♫ ]
- When somebody who's out there
in the world
doing the things that you admire
comes and spends time with you and pays
attention to you and tells you,
“Oh, yeah,
what you're doing is interesting, too,
and what you're doing
relates to what I'm doing.”
Those are the moments
you remember as a student.